bonsoir à tous soyez les bienvenus dans
votre journal de l'afrique l'algérie
d'abord où la plupart des incendies ont
été maîtrisés selon la protection civile
ce qui n'écarte pas pour autant le
risque de nouveaux départs de feu dans
la région de taff notamment les
habitants ont dû être évacués à titre
préventif
la volonté de bâtir la paix au tchad un
dialogue national et inclusif doit
s'ouvrir ce samedi à djamena en présence
d'une quarantaine de groupes armés deux
des principaux mouvements rebelles ont
en revanche refusé d'y prendre part eric
toppan à est notre invité dans ce
journal il est journaliste à la
rédaction francophone de la dette
chevelle
et puis nous vous emmènerons aussi en
angola le pays se prépare au scrutin du
24 août prochain les élections générales
candidat à sa réélection président
lorenzo a fait de la lutte contre la
corruption vous le verrez l'une de ses
priorités
la plupart des incendies sont ce soir
maîtrisé en algérie c'est en tous les
cas ce qu'ont annoncé les autorités de
gigantesques flammes ont consumé les
environs de style parfait et souk ahras
au moins 38 personnes ont péri parmi
lesquels onze enfants voyez ces images
commentées par sophie la botte
une tornade de feu qui n'a épargné
personne sur son passage laissant des
centaines d'hectares de forêts détruits
et des dizaines de morts parmi eux douze
personnes ont été brûlés vifs dans cette
auto car
la route était fermée et il n'y avait
pas d'échappatoire il n'y a nulle part
où s'échapper regardez le feu a couvert
toute la région il y avait deux jeunes
enfants dans cet autocar qui sont morts
ils sont morts en se serrant les uns
contre les autres en s'enlaçant dans les
provinces d'al tarif est de sétif les
animaux non plus n'ont pas pu échapper
aux flammes
ces agriculteurs ont perdu leur maison
leurs récoltes et leurs bétails
c'est notre gagne pain nous sommes des
agriculteurs nous élevons du bétail
comme des moutons des vaches et des
poulets
nous n'avons nulle part où aller et plus
rien pour vivre
le premier ministre algérien aymen ben
abderrahmane a visité les régions les
plus touchées ce jeudi
c'est là que les trois hélicoptères
bombardiers d'eau ont été déployées avec
le soutien de l'armée certains disent
qu'il y avait trop peu de capacités
aériennes disponibles et accuse les
autorités d'être mal préparée malgré le
nombre record de victimes dans les
incendies de l'année dernière qui ont
tué 90 personnes et ravagé cent mille
hectares de forêt
voilà pour les derniers développements
puis on va retrouver fayçal métaoui en
direct d'alger bonsoir à vous faille
seul on a évoqué l'instant dans ce sujet
des experts ont pointé du doigt des des
lacunes dans le dispositif anti-incendie
ce qu'il y ait eu effectivement une
impréparation un manque de bombardier
face à à la situation
contre les incendies a été adopté en
début d'année et selon le gouvernement
pour peut retenir les leçons de l'année
passée et doute 2021 des feux ont ravagé
plus de cent mille hectares de forêt
provoqué la mort de 90 personnes un plan
et qui prend en charge beaucoup beaucoup
de spe dont justement l'utilisation de
canadair l'algérie a prêté un bombardier
d'eau ou russe c'est un briec b200 mais
qui a été endommagée selon le ministre
de l'intérieur ces derniers jours il
devrait être en service
théoriquement la semaine prochaine et
selon des médias l'algérien annuler un
contrat d'achat d'avions bombardiers
d'eau conclut avec une firme espagnole
en raison de la crise diplomatique entre
les deux pays le premier ministre a eu
malgré de la semaine annoncé que le
gouvernement met tous les moyens de
l'état pour prévenir et de lutter contre
les incendies et que de nouveaux
mécanismes sera adoptée à la rentrée et
parmi ces deux mécaniques la location ou
l'achat de canadair pour justement
lutter contre les incendies puisqu'ils
sont de plus en plus avant 20h notamment
cédé ces dernières années et aujourd'hui
même la dia les unités d'intervention de
la protection civile continue de lutter
contre les feux notamment dans la région
de tarbes sur parole à skikda à l'est et
à tipaza et ce vendredi aussi des coûts
routes ont été coupées peu après la
reprise de feu parce qu'il ya un banquet
a repris dans cette région du nord-est
algériens et des évacuations préventives
merci à vous à fayçal fayçal métaoui en
direct depuis alger
s'ils tiennent les engagements pris le 8
août dernier à doha au qatar les groupes
d'opposition civile et les factions
rebelles et la junte au pouvoir se
retrouveront ce samedi à djamena ce
dialogue annoncé comme inclusif doit
ensuite ouvrir la voie des élections
présidentielle et législatives sauf que
le fact le front pour l'alternance et la
concorde au tchad ne participera pas ces
échanges au même titre que le collectif
fois quittâmes à une manifestation de ce
mouvement a d'ailleurs été dispersés par
la police ce vendredi bonsoir à vous
eric topo n'a cette journaliste à la
rédaction francophone de la 2e vélo vous
est notamment l'auteur de cet ouvrage et
c'est pour la refondation du tchad un
livre publié en décembre 2021 merci
d'avoir accepté l'invitation france 24
on va tenter de d'analysé décrypte
ensemble et les défis et les enjeux de
ce dialogue inclusif et et national mais
d'abord je viens de l'évoquer à
l'instant il y eut cette manifestation
lancée par le mouvement le collectif
même moi qui te tama qui a été dispersée
par la police et school le message là
n'est pas un peu brouillée d'empêcher
d'interdire une manifestation de
l'opposition à la veille même d'une
tentative de réconciliation moi je pense
qu'il faudrait d'abord lancé disant le
placer le contexte ce dialogue national
et m moment historique pour le chat pour
essayer de proposer des pistes pour
refonder le pays la coalition a dit aman
fait partie des organisations de la
société civile qui ont refusé de
participer à ce dialogue parce que elle
estime que les conditions posées n'ont
pas été prises en compte par la junte on
aurait pu peut-être les autoriser à
manifester mais le fait que cette fois
les gens ne participent pas à ce
dialogue est regrettable j'espère
qu'elle va donc se raviser rejoindre la
dynamique pour essayer de faire des
propositions pour sortir le pays de
l'ornière
au même titre que le fact le front pour
l'alternance et la concordance la
concorde au tchad j'en appelle aussi que
c'est ce même mouvement qui est à
l'origine de l'attaqué qui a coûté la
vie au président déby ans en avril 2021
le fait que ces deux mouvements
organisations rebelles
importante en tout cas existants est
présente au tchad ne participe pas cette
tentative de réconciliation est ce qu'il
n'ya pas déjà là en échec et et
peut-être même une compromission de
cette tentative de rebâtir la paix non
on ne peut pas parler d'échec parce que
à doha il y avait quand même 50 2 go
permet une bonne quarantaine a accepté
de signer c'est déjà un bon signe et
ceux qui n'ont pas signé non pas fermé
la porte à un matt m'a dit par exemple
leader du fact que j'ai interrogés sur
les antennes de la douleur claire m'a
dit que c'est parce que certaines de ces
conditions incertaines des conditions
posées par son mouvement n'ont pas été
prises en compte lesquels par exemple
ils exigent avant tout qu'on libère les
prisonniers du fact et le gouvernement a
pris acte puisque ça a été consignée
dans l'accord ne serait après donc il ya
des conditions qui n'ont pas été
respectés même amat mady n'a pas fermer
de portes et tout comme d'ailleurs les
autres formations politiques de
l'opposition qui refuse de participer ou
non et n'ont jamais dit qu'elle n'allait
pas participer à ce dialogue c'est que
savaient ce qu'elles peuvent changer
d'avis sur les trois semaines de
discussions la changer je suis optimiste
parce que tous s'accordent à dire qu'il
faut un dialogue il faut ce moment pour
discuter des problèmes du tchad mais
c'est une question de
deux conditions qui n'auraient pas été
respectées par la jeune militaire au
pouvoir qui fait coincer les choses et à
l'issue de ces discussions à ce que vous
pensez que l'échéance des dix-huit mois
de transition sera respectée ce qu'il y
aura la tenue d'élections en octobre
prochain il faut être réaliste la charte
de la transition actuelle a prévu une
conviction ils ont 10 18 mois les voilà
18 mois renouvelable
bon maintenant les chantiers de la
fondation du tchad sont immenses je ne
serais pas surpris que cette transition
soit
projet afin de permettre combien de
temps par exemple mais je pense que la
chapelle claire dumas renouvelable une
seule fois il faut renouveler il faut 18
mois de novembre - êtes-vous pour
justement organiser de bonnes élections
pour que le pays puisse pour une fois se
doter d'institutions républicaines et
surtout que les tchadiens puisque pour
une fois de l'histoire de choisir
eux-mêmes et librement leurs dirigeants
et je pense que c'est ce sont ces
chantiers là qui doivent être
discutées lors de ce dialogue et après
on pense à la banque une ère nouvelle à
l'issue d'élections générales ip est
enceinte merci beaucoup merci à vous
eric tu connais je pense qu'on verra de
nouveau pour faire le débrief de ce
processus de dialogue qui sera donc qui
va démarrer donc demain djamena il ne
s'agit pas des changes et une domination
contre une autre la formule et d'ousmane
sonko des mots prononcés lors de
l'annoncé de sa candidature à la
présidentielle 2024 un discours
souverainiste pleinement assumé je vous
propose de l'écouter
qui ne repose sur aucune colonie et qui
est la première puissance économique de
l'europe elle doit avoir la dignité de
peuple de voler de ses propres ailes
enfin et de continuer de sucer le sang
de ses ex colonies si c'est ça ne pas
aimer la france je ne m'aime pas et ce
discours n'est pas dirigé contre le
peuple français il est entendu écouté
mais il est dit surtout par beaucoup
d'acteurs politiques d'intellectuels
d'universitaires en france
pris lors de cette même conférence de
presse ousman sonko a tenu à apporter
son soutien à 6 me gohi talus dirigeant
de facto du mali voisin la
correspondance délit même d'un haut
depuis dakar le soutien de ce match ont
qu à assimiler et n est pas assez
surprenant si on se réfère au discours
habituel du principal opposant à macky
sall sur les relations internationales
un discours axé sur la souveraineté il a
réaffirmé à lors de son point de presse
ce jeudi le placement de son coin estime
que les pays africains notamment les
pays d'afrique francophone ne sont pas
assez s'ouvrir dans les relations
internationales avec les puissances
étrangères notamment avec la france ce
soutien intervient en tout cas quelques
jours après la visite officielle du
président macky sall à bamako a reçu par
assimi gridda pour réchauffer les
relations diplomatiques entre dakar et
bamako des relations tendues en début
d'année après l'entrée en vigueur de
l'embargo de la cedeao un embargo qui a
été partiellement levée il y à un mois
macky sall après cette visite a affirmé
vouloir apporter son soutien sa
solidarité au peuple frère du mali selon
soissons que sa démarche est pas assez
sincère semaine son coût continue
d'accuser macky sall comme étant un
défenseur plus des intérêts de la france
que des intérêts du sénégal et de
l'afrique à des accusations réfutées à
part des proches du président de la
république à ce discours en tout cas
d'ousmane sow sur la souveraineté son
soutien à simi brita a reçu un écho
assez favorable c'est une partie de
l'opinion qui estime que les relations
entre la france et l'afrique doit être
revu de façon générale la côte d'ivoire
maintenant les ambitions de simone
gbagbo l'ancienne première dame prête à
faire cavalier seul son mouvement des
générations capables elles pourraient
évoluer en parti politique dont elle
prendrait la direction la correspondance
de sadia mondiaux à abidjan
officiellement simone gbagbo est
toujours marraine du mouvement mais dès
samedi les choses pourraient changer car
c'est bien à la fin de ces deux jours
d'assemblée générale qu'on pourra
officiellement dire que l'ancienne
première dame a lancé son propre parti
politique un parti qui marquera
officiellement le divorce politique avec
son ancien mari l'ex-président laurent
gbagbo plusieurs personnalités
politiques ivoiriennes ont d'ailleurs
choisi leur camp sur la scène on a pu
apercevoir issiaka ce hangar et le
secrétaire général du front populaire
ivoirien le f pays ce parti fondé par
laurent et simone gbagbo a été la
première force politique du pays entre
2000 et 2011 lorsqu'il était à la tête
de la côte d'ivoire on a aussi entendu
et vu des membres du cojep le parti de
charles blé goudé ancien ministre sous
laurent gbagbo mais également d'autres
anciens exilés politiques qui étaient
proches de l'ancien président tous ont
confirmé leur soutien à simone gbagbo ou
non d'un passé commun actuellement la
question que tout le monde se pose c'est
est ce que simone ehivet gbagbo sera la
présidente de ce parti politique la
coordonnatrice du mouvement répond au
micro de france 24
déjà avant lorsque nous étions citoyens
mouvement citoyen elle lui disait que
c'était son booty politique parce que
nous avions le droit de parler suit les
choses politiques donc à partir de cette
ce droit là elle pouvait vous fait
partager sa vision politique est dans
que nous millions évidemment tout le
monde va en disant c'est certainement
madame gbagbo mais
c'est plus que ça soit quelqu'un d'autre
ce que l'on sait c'est que le mouvement
des générations capables est dans une
dynamique pour former des alliances et
occuper une place importante au sein de
l'opposition ivoirienne une stratégie
politique mise en place très
probablement en vue des élections
présidentielles de 2025
cap sur l'angola maintenant le pays se
prépare au scrutin du 24 août prochain
des élections générales l'occasion de
faire le bilan du mandat de joão
lourenço il ya cinq ans l'actuel chef de
l'état avait surpris en lançant dès son
entrée en fonction une vaste croisade
contre la corruption reportage à luanda
de clément boudreau et juliette du bois
pour france 24
pendant longtemps ces deux tours ont été
le visage du boom économique angolais
aujourd'hui elles sont devenues le
symbole de la lutte anti-corruption
parisien voici l'exemple que nous
pouvons montrer de ces deux bâtiments
ici le cif luanda one et le cif luanda
toutes ces photos
siph pour china international fund un
conglomérat chinois utilisés par des
hommes d'affaires angolais pour
détourner des millions de dollars
d'argent public il y a deux ans les deux
bâtiments ont été saisis par la justice
angolaise les propriétaires ont reconnu
que ces bâtiments ont été construits
avec de l'argent public et ils ont
décidé de les rendre à l'état
depuis son arrivée au pouvoir en 2010
est le président joint lorenzo a fait de
la lutte contre la corruption une
priorité le pays s'est doté de plusieurs
agences dédiées dont le service national
de récupération d'actifs dans ses
bureaux flambants neufs 17 employés
traque les milliards détournés des
caisses de l'état sous l'ancien
président josé eduardo dos santos la
justice angolaise affirme avoir déjà
récupéré 10 milliards d'euros d'actifs
et elle ne compte pas s'arrêter en si
bon chemin nous allons poursuivre les
investigations enquêter et demander des
comptes évidemment dans un combat comme
celui ci il n'est pas possible de
récupérer 100% de ce qui a été pris mais
le maximum qui peut être récupéré c'est
ça notre objectif
récupérer les ressources et renforcer
les ressources humaines et matérielles
de nos institutions qui sont en cinq ans
la justice angolaise a lancé plus de 700
poursuites pour des délits financiers et
de nombreuses personnalités de premier
plan ont été traduites en justice mais
pour une partie de la société civile
cette lutte est insuffisante et surtout
trop sélective
significative il ya eu des avancées
significatives
mais ces avancées pourrait également
signifier un retour en arrière s'il n'y
a pas de réformes sérieuses et si le
président ne fait pas preuve de
détermination pour combattre la
corruption au sein même de son
gouvernement
selon un classement établi par
transparency international l'angola
reste parmi les 50 pays les plus
corrompus de la planète malgré une
progression de 30 et une place depuis
2010 est c'est la fin de ce journal
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi rester sur
france 24 la formation continue
[Musique]